okay hopefully it'll help you do that
make that decision I'll talk a little
bit about what Brennan Flores has that
others may not have okay so that's what
I call gravy and now we'll do some
wrapping up
okay so before we talk about ramen for
us of course we need to talk about
cotton classification and regression
tree can I see a show of hands anybody
who no idea what Carl does to some
people so I will spend very brief amount
of time to tell you what carp does hey
so if you think about forward stepwise
regression I'm a statistician by the way
so I'm going to explain in statistical
terms so what stage what for stepwise
regression does is you have Y variable
you have a whole bunch of X variable you
try to build a model that predicts Y
from X right so what do you do you first
find the best variable among all your X
to predict Y and you put that in the
model and you go and find the second
best then you put it in then you find
this third best and so on and so forth
that's essentially what Carlos is doing
okay except it does it and even much
much greater way than what regression
does okay
so within a variable what it's going to
do is find a way to split the Y data so
that the to partition within each
partition there as similar as possible
and between the partitions is as
different as possible right so that's
what you're trying to do the
partitioning and the way it does that is
by searching through all possible ways
of splitting the data using a single
variable okay when it finds the best
splitting point they keep track of that
move on through the second variable
that again and want to go through all
the variable would pick the one with the
best best split and that's the one you
split up okay and then you have two
parts you take you go to each part and
repeat that process all over again until
you can't do it anymore
that's why I mean by finding gap that
the gap is where you do the split okay
and keep doing this until what I said
it's futile maybe that the partition is
so small it's not likely to work well
okay so the good thing about carped and
one of the good things is it very
naturally handles categorical and
numerical variables it doesn't care
whether or not a variable is categorical
or numerical it handles them just fine
now with numerical variable it just keep
finding the gaps in unique values to do
the split for categorical variable
basically search all possible way of
partitioning the category okay so if you
have a B and C and look for a versus B C
or a B versus C or AC versus B all
possible combinations okay so it's very
natural now you will find some tree
algorithm that don't do that it's an
implementation issue not the algorithm
ition okay so if your tree algorithm
doesn't do that complain to the
programmer he's being lazy so as you can
see it is very greedy algorithm okay
it's doing all these search so it's very
greedy and greedy means it's unstable a
tiny little bit of change in your data
can lead to completely different tree
structures okay so some people like the
tree algorithm because it's easy to
follow the rule
was that you yeah with the tree but just
because it's easy to follow doesn't mean
that the rules are quote unquote real or
reliable because the algorithm is
unstable if you somehow change the data
a little bit the tree structure can look
very different
okay so that makes the interpretive
ability part pretty shaky now the
algorithm can be easily parallelizable
easy if you are programmer who knows
what you're doing as you can see you
search through each variable for the
best split when you do that when you do
the search I'll say the first variable
has nothing to do what you do on there -
or any other variable so you can easily
parallelized a part right once you
partition the data into two parts what
you do on one side has nothing to do
with what you do on the other side so
that could be parallelized okay so the
original author carved one of the
original authors real Brian who's also
the original author ran a forest he had
worked down the parallel tree building
algorithm back in the AIDS so he's a
real pioneer even though well I won't
say much more than that finding the
right size tree so you can keep
splitting the data when do you stop
right so you keep splitting the data the
tree becomes
and it's complex it's not so
interpretable and the prediction that
isn't likely to be working so well so
you have to start somewhere the
innovation that leo breiman
Jerry Freeman ocean and stone they wrote
the original Carl book back in the 80s
the innovation is that they use close
validation to figure out where to trim
the tree down so that has good
predictions the tree algorithm had its
origin in the sixties in the social
science so you know it's it's nothing
new what was new was how you actually
find the right light street before that
they were doing hypothesis testing that
every single split to see you know do I
need to stop here or do I keep going
okay so that was the innovation then the
last unfortunate thing about Clark was
it's generally not the most accurate
algorithm when it comes to prediction
okay look what I just want that's luck
would have it I just happened to pick
the iris dataset so here is a simple
depiction this is out of laziness there
I had no idea I would see this
sorry about the gif animation I should
have not keep having it cycle but I
don't know how to stop it from cycling
but so this is basically how a tree
works I'm only using two variable on the
iris dataset so there are three species
right I'm simply using two variables so
I can do autograph it takes that first
root node that has all the data that
search through both variables to see
which one is best at splitting the data
into two pieces
okay once it does that and I guess this
is the first one what no I'm sorry here
okay so it split off that part then
split right here then the split right
here then it split right there so the
important thing is that it does it in
the recursive manner that's why it's
also called recursive partitioning okay
and then you see the usually you see the
model being represented as the upside
down tree that's why it's called a
classification tree and if you're doing
the question that wasn't the question
tree okay so here we're in the forest in
one slide what you do is obviously it's
called Horace so there's got to be I'll
have a lot of trees right so how do you
get a lot of tree from the single
dataset this this thing here let's see
okay so this is my data statistician I'm
a statistician or data scientist
probably work the same way we like to
see nice rectangular data table right so
suppose you already have that what
you're going to do is draw random
samples from this data set and when I
say Joe random sample simply means
you're sampling the rows the data the
observations are in the row variable and
columns okay so you're sampling the rows
don't worry too much about whether
you're assembling with replacement or
without replacement that part is not so
important okay so you do that a bunch of
times and every random sample that
you've got you see you have all the
variable but only subset of the rows
what you're going to do is take that
first random sample you start building
you a treat okay except that when you're
doing the splits you don't search
through all the variable like you would
in cart so you see that I have eight
variables and that first split I only
randomly picked three okay I'm only
looking for the best out of those three
instead of looking through all eight and
I do my split so here I have I can't see
where I'm pointing so this is useless
you you partition that into two pieces
and you go back to all your variables
and each of those pieces and again you
randomly sample some variables and only
look through those that you happen to
pick and find the best out of those now
this is a comfortable intuitive part
right
so in cart we know we look for the best
flip
and Rena Morris with their low girly one
the algorithm not to find if I split
well why would anybody do that right you
purposeful you want to dump down the
algorithm right so we'll talk about why
we do that that's part of why but
basically you just keep doing that
process until you can't do it anymore
so remember in the forest we don't do
pruning you grow the tree to the maximum
size well having what now or we'll talk
about why you might want to do
differently later and then you repeat
that same process for every single one
of these pure random safety okay that's
how you end up with whole bunch of trees
if you don't do the random sampling you
have the same data you're gonna end up
with the same trees not terribly
interesting so the rhythm is the random
sampling is what give you a whole bunch
of entry okay so I told you how to
generate all those trees how do you do
predictions right one thing that's sort
of bothering me I get email questions
from users and kid you not I gotten the
same question more times than I care to
remember people asking so - I grew a
random forest where's my final tree the
name is called random forests
okay you don't have us and go cheese
okay so here is my analogy of comparison
between these two algorithm so here is
carpet okay you can drive it everywhere
it's really easy to drive right not
particularly fast anybody want to guess
what random forest look like anybody
sorry okay
it's sort of like the original Beatles
except it's got a jet engine on it okay
I don't know how this technology is
because I would imagine the Beatles with
the jet engines still not as easy to
drive her the Beatles okay so you know
originally I tell Jared that I was
shocked that this session was booked so
fast and I guess I can stand here with a
straight face to say YRF is popular okay
so it inherits many of the advantages
from carped so what can cart what's the
good thing about car places very little
requirement found data pre-processing
right
it handles numerical variable older
categories on the order categories you
throw anything at it it's like a kitchen
sink okay so it's very user friendly
missing data no problem
well at least for the original car in
Rena for us that would be a problem but
that's an implementation issue now that
our the mission it turned out to be
quite high performance and the O'Brien
in his 2001 paper on Brennan forests
make the claim that it doesn't know
Firth head and that was one big
attraction for random forest for those
of you who have play around with many
machine learning algorithm
would know that overfitting is a issue
that rather difficult to tackle
sometimes
okay so Rama forest at least sort of
protect you from that
okay so there is this paper from I guess
almost four years ago from the machine
learning journal of machine learning
research that was interesting
somebody actually took the time together
I believe all the data set in the UC
Irvine machine learning repository there
are like hundreds of data set some small
some large and they went through all I
don't know about all available available
algorithms and careth for those of you
who use carob you know epic era that has
like 237 available methods okay and
these guys test them all okay that's
what this paper is about okay so if
you're interested in huge gigantic
benchmark study this is interesting know
what was interesting is they actually
saw some patterns from doing that and
what was the pattern they saw well the
title of that paper sort of give you a
him do we really need this many
classifier there main conclusion was
random forest type algorithm not not
this particular implementation but there
are several implementations of rena
porous in the carrot package well
they're basically scattered throughout
are those type of algorithm I think was
number one and summary
percentage of these data it's 90 some
percent okay so if you try to pick a
winner amount all the algorithm for the
forest would be it okay
sort of close second will be support
vector machine nothing else can close
for white applicability now some of you
must have heard of the nobody lunch
there right well here's your free lunch
seems like okay so here is my attempt at
explaining why random forests work so
we're using multiple models instead of a
single model and if you look at this toy
at example here the first column
why is my class label zero and one and
then all the other columns are the
different models that I'm contemplating
and combining okay and their predictions
the boxes do a color then where were
they met made mistakes and at the bottom
you will see the accuracy of those
classifier right along six data points
the first one is right two votes at the
time the second one got one out of six
wrong the third one is also 2/3 2/3 and
the last one is only half okay and what
I'm going to do the way I'm going to
make predictions just like I would in
Rena forest imagine these your five
trees okay and I'm going to combine the
predictions I'm simply going to look
across each row and see which class is
predicted most and that's food that's
the prediction okay
and lo and behold when I do that I get
hundred percent accuracy sorry majority
rule if you have more than two classes
that's horrible
whichever class got the Mosel doesn't
have the
right so is that convincing enough this
is our random force work essentially
this is actually how any ensemble method
should work okay how do you get it to do
this that's the question
okay so the requirement the sort to
basic requirement one is that each of
these model has to do a little at least
a little bit better than random guessing
they could do a lot better than random
guessing but the least they have to do
do better than random guess - is that
the mistakes they make they need to try
to make mistakes around different data
points okay think about if I'm trying to
define a whole bunch of classifier that
all have 99% accuracy but everybody make
the wrong prediction on the same data
point I get no mileage at all by
combining them right I only get mileage
from combining these models when they
make mistakes on different things right
so not only I need them to do a little
bit better than random but I the most
important part is I need diversity okay
I need them to make a mistake in
different parts okay so to give you an
example of how ensemble works and not
just in classifier after I made the job
of this presentation I sent it around to
a bunch of my colleagues at work and
said you know I'm giving this talk in
New York do you guys mind looking it
over and giving your suggestions in
comments hello in the house of all
people bother to go through the
presentation and they send me feedback
the amazing thing the absolutely amazing
thing is a whole bunch of people found
quite a few titles nobody found the same
title
literally nobody found the same typo
okay so this is straight out of real
diamonds paper and then a fourth this is
how he explains how the algorithm works
you have correlation among the base
models that you're combining and you
have strength of individual models that
you're combining okay so correlation is
basically how similar those predictions
are and strength is how accurate those
cloud suppliers are so that's basically
what I was talking about right diversity
and how different they predict they
cannot make a mistake out of the same
program same data points and they need
to be a little better than random so if
you have low correlation that implies
diversity and if you have those
classifiers all protecting quite well
then they basically have to be highly
correlated right because the basic we do
give you very similar predictions on the
same data point okay so basically you're
trying to design ensemble that will give
you a good compromise between these two
okay so the single tuning parameter and
random forests according to Brian is
this Finkel and try and remember I
talked about when you do split you don't
search through all variables the number
of variable that you randomly picked to
search through is this parameter oh I'm
trying
in cart you have no choice its search
through all the variables okay so as you
can imagine when you use very small m
try it basically make the trees more
different right so that promotes
diversity one thing when I first started
looking around for is what amazed me was
even when you said my equal to one that
basically means every time you do the
split you are so lazy you simply
randomly pick one and say this is the
one I'm going to split on even that
works okay that's the amazing thing
well enough most of the time anyway okay
so here is one way of looking at random
forests or what it's doing so I'm going
to take again the iris dataset and again
the two variables the graph on top is
the predictive probability of a single
tree using those two variables so I
think I was trying to predict whatever
this class was I think it was mercy
caller okay so you see both of those
data points are in the blue so that's
the class I was predicting and you can
see that it was a very very boxy
that's what tree does that give you a
rectangular hyperbola ition of the data
okay and within each of those you get a
prediction all the same predictions
within each of those boxes okay and
basically if you think about what it's
doing it's trying to find neighborhoods
and your data space where within each
neighborhood
similar enough that you can predict them
all with the same class okay so you can
think about it as a weight of doing
nearest neighbor except that you're not
limited to how many neighbors you have
and you let the data speak for itself as
to what variable you've used to define
the neighborhood and where you cut to
define the neighborhood except that it
give you this very rough cut the
neighborhood has to be rectangular right
because it does the split one variable
at a time so it doesn't do curve okay so
what do you get when you do random
forests well and random forests you do
this lots and lots and lots and lots of
times default 500 times okay and when
you do that because every tree is
somewhat different from the other those
boxes are basically shifting a little
bit every single time and what you're
doing is you are averaging over all
those and you ended up with the blood
ocean at the bottom okay so your
neighborhood is no longer well defined
like the top nor is it boxing like the
power okay so it's you can think of it
as neighbor wadn't because you know
phase they're along the boundaries of
these fuzzy parts the weight gets
smaller and smaller okay so it basically
behaves like sort of effective nearest
neighbors okay so what controls or this
model complexity that's a big question
so if you look at random forests as
adaptive way that nearest neighbor
well what controls model complexity and
nearest neighbor that's K right the size
of the neighborhood so if you think of
random forest as a way to nearest
neighbor then the size of the
neighborhood controls the model
complexity right so what happened when
you had more trees in reservoirs
why would leo breiman say the number of
tree is not a tuning parameter it's not
something you worry about well because
when you increase the number of trees
all you're doing is make those
boundaries more and more blur you don't
make them more complex okay so your
boundary becomes smoother instead of
boxing thing but they don't become more
complex so number of tree really isn't a
tuning parameter so size of neighborhood
can be an indicator of model complexity
okay so there is evidence that small
trees and random forests work better
than large trees for some data so in the
original publication leo breiman our
view for gluing the trees to the maximum
size okay you split the data until we
can't do it anymore okay so you end up
with these gigantic trees that weigh
over that data and then you average them
there was a paper from
Frankl was 2004 sequel where he actually
show that or some data set there is
something to be gained if you don't grow
your tree to maximum sorrow okay
and now when you didn't sort of
understand why right because if you
limit the tree size then you're
basically saying I want to use larger
pieces of neighborhood to do my
predictions and if your data if there
happened to be more suitable for you
there then
well that's it okay so given the same
data given the same training data
smaller trees will give you watching
neighborhood right you stop splitting
early so each node will end up with more
data so you're averaging over larger
area in your model space you're in that
space okay so here is a graph that sort
of shows you the trade-off between the
strength and correlation so what I did
is I took simulated data set I'll show
you which simulation I did what I did is
I because is simulated so I can have
chains that I can have pests that come
from exactly the same model and what I
did is I look at the individual tree
position if I grew 500 trees the average
prediction is don't identity here I'm
looking at the individual prediction of
those
so I can look and I can look right so if
I have the 500 tree forest
I'll talk on two set of predictions I
can compute a 500 by 500 correlation
matrix right I can take the me and out
of those pairwise correlation and that's
what I'm plotting here every day the
point is they ran the ball and those
random forests were built using those
parameters so I use different than try
and I use different no sighs okay no no
sighs basically sort of control how far
I split okay so larger null size meaning
I have smaller trees okay and as you can
see what happens when you change and try
is when you let them try become larger
okay the coalition goes up because each
individual trees are doing something
that's more similar when you use smaller
and try the treats are more different
therefore the Coalition goes down okay
but as you down down the algorithm by
using a smaller and try even though we
make the trees more diverse but then you
take
and prediction accuracy with the
individual trees okay so that that's the
graph on the lot on the right instead of
changing no sighs I'm changing something
else which I call synthesized now
remember in the slide where I explained
random forests as a random sample I
didn't say how many you draw right so
the same size is that parameter how many
data points do you randomly tall tree
okay here I'm expressing it as a percent
of my training set yes
the higher the higher than try if you're
in trying equal to the number of
variable you have then you're just using
card right so each tree will be more
similar because you look just as hard
every time right so just think about
what happened when I'm China is equal to
1 right every time I do I split the data
I'm just gonna randomly pick a pair of
it that's gonna make my the tree that I
build be more different than the next
tree I built because I simply do the
random pecking to split the data right
whereas I searched through all the day
they're all the variable there will be
allowing for more similar okay so you
can see the trade-off between the queue
okay so
here for those of you who have been
frustrated with the fact that you can't
really change
Venna forest here is hopefully some good
news for you here's some suggestion
things you can try so you can use em try
to balance coalition and strengthen
larger no size as I said forced through
the algorithm to produce smaller trees
and therefore larger neighborhood a
smaller set size also make the tree
smaller but how the two are not the same
because when you use smaller size the
final partition where you cannot live
any more
whatever theta you have left there if
you're doing the question you just
average those right if you do if you
want a very small sub sample those small
sub temples are the only data that is
see it doesn't seem to pay that you
didn't include okay so that's not the
same that use a larger know type and
therefore when you use simple when you
use to the size of the sub sample to
control the tree size you probably want
to increase your number of trees because
we can't afford to average a lot or
cheap right your choice of a lot more
diverse so here is the data that I
simulated from the number one okay
German and then has Mars paper from the
Viking
I think it was 84 okay he set up three
unofficial simulation where there is a
regression problem with 10 variable 5 a
real the other five were pure noise and
these five variables were sinusoidal and
there were complex interactions and
whatnot basically to test these
nonparametric regression problems
algorithms so here are my different
attempt of tuning Brennan Poros found
this data okay just to prove to you that
you can actually tune them and forth
right so in this first example I change
no sighs okay
that controls decides of the tree and M
Charlie okay so what was remarkable is
that one thing you might have heard
about reinforced if I have used it is
that it only has one tuning parameter
and it's not terribly sensitive to it
okay so that's good news if you're a
general user it's frustrating if you're
a data miner or machine learner because
you know no matter how you turn the
crank your answer doesn't change much
okay this is a terrible thing you choose
for a Carol competition right okay so
you see that for this particular that is
that I just mentioned before that for
some data set tend to prefer larger null
size meaning you don't go out a tree so
much well at least for this particular
setting that seems to prefer pretty
small no side so pretty large trees
right so more than I don't remember I
think it was a few thousand it say
either
three thousand or five thousand
something in
range that's the simple sighs okay so on
the x-axis that's the null sighs yes
this is some peso right so you wouldn't
do this on real data right you don't
tune your algorithm on the test set this
is like your validation set if it well
okay
so it prefers small note signs meaning
large tree if you look at and try the
default is here okay so it actually
prefers slightly larger and chai if you
do banging that's when you search for
all the variables you actually do a
little worse than the default okay now
what about if you choose sent sighs okay
you will see that and random for us if
you don't specify sent sighs it doesn't
a regular boostrap which pick up about
63% of your Chinese up every time so
that's about 63% it's the bell right
here so you can see that it's the
optimal what's quite close to the
default okay and the last plot I just
picked the best time try and vary the
other two what you do see the current
okay so real brahmins plain Brenda not
over
this is I would say this is really in
comparison to boosting okay in some
sense bagging boosting and metaphors has
quite a bit of any similar in similarity
okay they all use more cheese they all
combine more cheese but they go about it
in very different ways and the number of
trees do you have in boosting really not
comfortable to the number of trees you
have hey so like I said red of course
there's not overfed basically refers to
the number of trees you run a forest you
can have as many treats as you want it's
not going to over for the daily in the
sense that you're not gonna go up as
your number of trees go march off to
infinity you can't do that with boosting
right usually when you boost beyond say
a couple thousand trees it starts
overfitting that's not before that okay
so why are they different
okay so when it comes to overfit this is
my pet peeve the neural network guys
like to use this notion that if your
training error and your test set error
or validation error is diverging your
overfitting
that may be true for neural network that
is absolutely not true for boosting or
rena force okay because you think about
what these are what boosting and brand
the force is doing it over fits the
training data but it keeps the error
rate on the test set low okay so what
happens in renofloor is a boosting is
not the same thing as
see network okay so why is it because
Rena for let's go to the tree to make
some insights it deliberately tried to
fit overhead the data in every tree when
you combine them of course it's gonna
over set the training back Chinese okay
and the same thing with boosting and
what was amazing about boosting is what
they found sort of accidentally said
that the original ADA boost algorithm
they don't know when to stop right in
the forest doesn't matter when you stop
you can compute until you don't feel
like it and boosting the question when
do you stop the original algorithm says
when your training error goes to 0 then
you stop okay somebody had the bright
idea keep going even after training
euros
zero and they found the test that error
is still going down that was the big
mystery can you boost forever and they
found out eventually there's no hint
okay so bottom line is again the gap
between your training set error and your
test set error it's not a good
indication of overfitting it's really
whether or not when your model
completely up your peasant error or
generalization error keep going up that
is what I will consider overfitting okay
so comparing random forests and
loosening them independently okay so you
can easily paralyze this you can grow a
tree down if you have a thousand no
cluster you can grow one tree on every
single cluster on every node and combine
them okay that's an easy way of coming
down to your training Tony you can't do
that boosting that's a sequential
algorithm you can paralyze the tree
construction
then each iteration but the sequence is
not parallelizable okay some people must
have used the package XG boost right
that's a very popular package right it
parallelized a tree constructions but it
cannot paralyze the boosting sequence
compain random forests use randomness to
get diversity right remember from that
slide down how long Samba works you need
diversity in your base protector the way
the diversity and boosting it's not hey
and that's why Houston is sequential
you fit a pretty lousy model to your
data you get your illusion from a Fed
and you try to improve oh okay so what
happened when you do that your shall we
say I model is trying to be different
than your previous model so that's quite
delivery right and random for us and
just jumping all around by chance in
boosting it doesn't do that okay in rena
for us leo breiman would say well the
treated maximum size in boosting is
usually grow very small trees okay in
random forests number of tree is not a
tuning parameter okay you should grow as
many treats as your computation
those allows and boosting you can't you
have to figure out what stoppable if you
do too many then you over fit no I
should point out one good thing about
these things versus say something like
speaking on that and you keep doing that
unless you do I've got the term a future
unless you keep track what Brahman is
for you ma o checkpointing okay if you
do checkpointing because you're a model
is sequential right so if you found now
after you grew to thousand trees that
you started overfitting that maybe you
should only use publishing okay
you can just say stop predicting after
fifteen undertaker ignore the last 500
treats and voila you're you can't really
do that with okay because in Brenham 4c
typically grow something like on the
side so the model tend to be rather
large as well the larger your dataset
the launch of the tree because keep
going the tree to the maximum fine so
watcher that they did the walk you
tomorrow
so if you really have gigantic amount of
data the way to go about it to use a
small segment side so you don't you're
essentially still growing on smaller
subset of your data and you can afford
to grow more of them or to its use no
side to control the tree size okay
and boosting you typically limit one of
the to be broke is how big the tree so
your mouth is essentially fit
[Music]
okay so here is a visual comparison the
behavior of these two algorithm so what
i did it again i took that freeman
number one simulation setup i took i
think this is a hundred data point from
the test server okay i I have random
forest and two different boosting model
what I'm looking at is in Brenham for as
I think I have the default 500 trees so
in my test set I have hundred a two
point protected by five hundred trees I
have this hundred by five hundred data
set right so if I flip that so now I
have five hundred rolls and one hundred
columns okay and I'm going to do
multi-dimensional scaling projection to
see how those trees the prediction that
those trees spread out and sort of a 2d
space and you can see that it's random
there's no pattern to it right the
person tree is the circle with the last
tree is the square and you know you can
pick any two data points and label them
circle with squared it doesn't matter
right in the middle one I did that with
a boosting model okay
thanks to Brett which way the author of
the GBM package he actually in some
version not on a one when because in the
beginning he didn't have that feature
but you actually get you can ask for
predictions of individual trees okay so
that's how I generate those okay you can
see that this is where it started this
is where it ends
that's quite deliberate right it looked
like it's doing optimization right that
it's taking big steps in the beginning
right and the big steps were go sort of
wobbly going in opposite directions and
eventually the settles down okay
so again now I use because it's like
okay and see what happens when you do
that the behavior is quite different
than the one where you have big step
size and number of iterations okay and
what's interesting is that these two
different parameters I basically give
you the same prediction perform
okay so how does random forest compared
to leave me alone n well having more
trees in the forest doesn't seem to
increase model complexity right I said
that multiple times and they've known
that complexity is basically
predetermined by you in that world
architecture you decide how many layers
you want to go you decide how many nodes
you want to have in each and layer that
is your model complexity right all the
others are basically your optimization
parameters whether you do drop out
what's your a learning rate those are
just up incision algorithm parameters
okay and random for us it doesn't do an
explicit optimization
okay that doesn't seem to try to go
somewhere that's sort of the magic in
boosting and indeed your network you
actually do optimization with control
read like polarization is basically
controlling how we so in Renault forest
prediction cannot exceed the range of
the training data because you're taking
average of some data points in your data
set so that cannot that's bounded by
whatever you data you have in the
training set
indeed you on that work if you're using
something like a ray Lu or some
activation function that's not founded
you can end up with prediction that's as
high as you want depending on your data
okay in random forests and tree based
model in general when you get a new
batch of data it's not so trivial on how
you go about updating your model with
the new data okay Hindi doing that work
that's trivial
you simply feed the data into your
application element to update your
that's how you do channel learning
basically right okay so my one of my
collaborators in the company
he's a computational chemist
that this comparison for those of you
who have seen the casual competition
from 2012 geez it's quite a while ago
that Merck hosted this competition 15
datasets okay the first-place winner was
a big new in network okay that's what
got us interested in looking at the
queuing network if you remember from
that competition the benchmark was
random forests okay so after the comes
we took a look at Dino Network and
basically here are 30 data sets so 15
those were the original elevated and the
additional 15 and what you see on the
x-axis is the test set R square I
shouldn't call it I swear this is simply
square correlation okay from random
forests predictions and the pesticides
on the y axes are the score correlation
for different algorithms the two
versions would be no network one is a
four layer DQ Lynette
okay that's basically what the winning
entry from the competition was doing
four layer Network the simpler one is a
two layer neural network that basically
took way less time way smaller model
size and there's just slightly worse in
prediction okay and then there is
actually boost which does about the same
as he's no network and those you can see
that they do on the average somewhat
better than render for it okay but not
universal okay now with random forest
there is absolutely
tuning at all and there's hunter trees
hey the chemists want to use this
application where it doesn't have a tune
anything ok so even the deep neural
network and actually boost we spend
quite a bit of time to find a set of
parameters that works across just about
all the in set well we did it on 15 and
then we test those parameters on the
other 15 and whoa behold they work well
I was afraid that they were going to
over fit on the 15 to do that but they
didn't okay but you know for this kind
of applications yes you do have some
games not by much and the computational
resource you need for deep neural
network it's quite formidable
here is training time comparison excuses
blazing past okay random forest if you
have small data set it's quite fast keep
newer network universally slow and you
know this is with GPU compared to just
CPU right eventually you know if you
don't control the size of the trees in
random forest it's going to help pace
even deep doing that so when you have
large data set you want to put some
control on the size of the trees here is
the model size now
I have to go back and check with this
guy because the model size for boosting
and DP Lynette with all be more or less
constant right they don't they shouldn't
change with simple size but you can see
that random forest when you don't put
help tree can be
okay so one other reason that Rena Ford
was popular as I hear coming up this
fing program variable importance so this
is something that other black box
algorithm the quote-unquote don't have
and that you know you've trained those
algorithm good prediction but you don't
know why gives you good prediction with
random forests you get this very
important don't mess with it okay
the idea I think can be applied to other
black box algorithm and here is how you
can go about this one possible way how
you can do it so you got your black box
method you're a trained model okay if
you have a holdout set like a test set
that's right there you feed in your
training model and you get you a test
set error right okay so how about
they're going for do is take you a
holdout set take one of your variable
the one you're interested in take the
first one okay and you randomly shall
hold the values okay so you have your
rectangular table you take that column
and you shuffle the value in that column
okay you take that dataset and feed it
and put it in your model and get your
error the difference between these two
error tells you something about how
important that variable is
look see okay I see how many people can
find more slide no more typos but anyway
so you repeat that a few times for every
variable okay and then you average them
and although I saw that's very important
okay and random forest it does this for
every tree remember you are using a
random sub sample to grow a tree so the
left out part is basically this holdout
data okay so you can do this on every
tree and then the onions to combine the
oil results and that's your variable
importance okay but if you don't have
random for us you can still do those if
you have a holdout set it wouldn't be
exactly the same but it will be similar
okay and it's fairly easy to code right
anybody comes like this and not write
partial dependence wow this is not firm
really porous business from Jerry
Freeman's ideas but hey so variable
importance tell you how important a
variable is but you don't know in what
way is important okay so partial
dependence pop give you some hint about
why is this variable important so your
general workflow would be you train your
algorithm until you get something you're
happy with okay let's give you good
predictions now you want to see why it
works how it works you first generate
your variable importance you take the
first few variable that has high
importance and you do one of these
okay dependents to figure out exactly
that's important and the way this works
is you take this what your prediction
function your train model is basically a
multivariate function right you have
more
important you probably the follower give
you a prediction right that's a
multivariate function and what you're
going to do is well let me just use this
this is how you calculate partial
dependence okay here's your data sorry
what you're going to do is replace the
first variable that first column with
some value okay so take out everything
in that first column and replace
everything with the same value and you
feed that into your chain model you make
a prediction okay after you get all
those predictions the average those
predictions that's the value of the
partial attendance function at one point
two okay you put in all the other values
that you saw in x1 and you would keep
repeating those do you end up with a
pair that's a partial dependence that
give you a relationship x1 idea how
those two are related
except that because your function is
quite complex that could have highly
complex interactions this is basically
your average defects right because
you're basically taking this
multivariate function and integrate out
all the other variables except the one
you're interested in okay and that
integration you approximate by you loser
averaging okay and lo and behold are
there in now
different packages that will give you
that for any black box algorithm so
there is a PDP puzzle dependent spot
this is something called a la la tiny
icebox
okay and those will have some other
variations baseball so but as an
interval I thought this seems to me this
ought to be something that a lot of
people would care about but law doesn't
seem to be used a whole lot I don't know
it's not easy to generate them or what
so there is a package for estimating the
conditional media at a particular input
what correct porous does is estimated
quantile okay basically percentile right
and that's exactly what we want in
prediction interval right so if I have a
in the future when I collect data at
this particular enzyme I expect the
actual data to be with 90% of those data
albeit with vendors in German okay so
think about how that compares to simply
doing regression regression give you the
point
petracles I'll you you give me a data
point I'll give you what the prediction
is I have no idea how confident you are
about how they are they that data point
might be the proficient in doubles sort
of give you a hint about how confident
you can be about that prediction
interval is wide that basically says
well I don't really know what the state
of point is right versus is that pretty
sure the future data is gonna lie
somewhere in here so I would think this
is something that's pretty useful now
Oh
right you're basically estimating a
distribution rather than a point
well so what Kharagpur is does going
back to talking about well I follow
these maybes I'm going to say that give
me the approximate conditional
distribution so I'm going on now that's
what Conrad for us is doing okay so if
you look at other algorithms such as say
XT police or things like that they might
you might coerce those algorithm to give
you quantiles except that the way you
have to do it is you have to change the
optimization objective function okay so
you have to go back and do your boosting
over again well as we file you want so
if you want a interval you need to have
a lower limit you have to have a upper
limit okay so that means you need to do
a boosting for your lower limit you have
to do another boosting for your upper
limit you end up with three different
models just to do prediction and the two
interval what Conrad Boris does is or
does is you call a random forest it
takes that forest pre-process but
post-process the neighborhood
information to get those fun files and
there you have the protectionism no
additional model 30 Hey so quite
convenient
and there is a recent package called GRL
generalizer in the forest
it basically pushed that idea further to
do local likelihood that's something
that statisticians away about okay okay
so pretty much winding down the package
as I said the package I wrote was 16 17
year old oh my god my son I'm not a
programmer
therefore apologies to those people who
had used the package over the user some
embarrassing bugs in there and there is
still quite a bit of room for
improvement in this package and I'm
actually quite glad there are
independent implementations so one such
invitation for example is the package
carranger and I was surprised the way
they validate their packages by checking
the result against a result they got
from my package so I hope doing that we
producing like bugs okay so anyway some
people have noticed that the requestion
you can do classification of the
question with random forests what people
have noticed yeah when you do the
questions everyone a lot slower than if
you run classification okay and the
reason for that is if you think about
what a tree algorithm is doing it keeps
sorting your data because in order to do
split you need to sort the data become
just want you to do the split and if you
are growing the tree lots of times
you're basically repeating the sorting
operation
and over again hey so in the
classification algorithm Leo had taken
the trouble of pre sorting the data and
store the sorted result and in the tree
growth part all he does is look up
that's all the results except that he
didn't bother to do that with the
regression code that's why the
aggression was lost lower so
implementation right now the depth of
the tree in random forests is not
charged okay so it's difficult to say I
want to use depth of trees as a measure
of model complexity okay so that's
something we should be able to address
supposing criteria as I mentioned in the
next abuse you've been customized there
supposing criteria you want to use which
is basically an objective function in
random forests that's hard coded in the
Fortran okay so difficult to customize
handling of large number of categories I
started with saying that when I first
wrote a package that was basically just
taking Julio Bryan's Fortran code and
put the our interface on Pablo
he used a four byte integer as a bit
field to encode which category goes last
which category goes right okay so
naturally doing a little bit by 32
category well I mean you take out the
sign bit not as a big deal but i integer
to encode the split so that goes up to
about 53 categories that's my sort of
cheek fix but there's gotta be a better
way and simply I don't have the
programming expertise to implement that
that's all okay missing value handling
right now it doesn't do any except that
you need to impute it if you computer
then it will handle it so that could be
better there have been people who also
took the package and customize it so
that a runs blazing-fast Allen special
data structure okay
so it's possible to do that for example
if you have binary data the tree
algorithm is way simpler when you have
binary data okay so this is my last
slide so hopefully I convinced you that
were anaphoras is flexible its robust
and it has pretty high performance this
machine learning methods leo breiman
calls it
machine whirring with doing machine
learning with two lines open okay and
hopefully I've given you some basic
understanding of how the algorithm works
and when you understand that you have
some better idea of how to go about
tuning their algorithm okay and you know
large data set you want to try small
same size and grow more trees and
hopefully also convince you that
something dodgy is only how you go
beyond just having a black box okay and
[Music]
thanks to all the collaborators well leo
breiman
they'll color those they're the original
author of the algorithm one miss Rennick
he was the person who got me working on
then enforce hey I should hate him for
it as you love him for it Matt Weiner
who had been my colleague who sort of
helped me finish the R package back when
we started 17 years ago
numerous summer interns have helped me
work down this package some more and
then there have been a lot of users who
use the package and unfortunately they
come bugs and I managed to fix some of
them not all of them there's still some
outstanding bugs and a lot of people
were making suggestions and this morning
I've got another email somebody saying
well can you do this yeah why didn't I
think of that okay so if you use the
packaging you think you have good
suggestions
send them all
[Applause]
right
so you're talking about the you're
asking about the bias in their
importance right so for the name of this
Caroline struggle I think I'm
pronouncing the name right okay they
actually so a package called pardon in
are that has yet another implementation
with rainforest they call see for us
okay the see doesn't mean classification
its conditional okay so they're growing
tree by using traditional inference and
in there they implemented a it's
somewhat so the condition the bias that
you're talking about comes from the bias
in creating this place if you think
about algorithm go about doing the split
as I said it's very greedy algorithm
this kind of search through all possible
their way to split if you have say
thirty data points right and you have a
numeric variable and all of their values
are unique you have 29 places where you
can do the split okay if it's binary you
only have one place to do the split okay
when you compare those two okay majority
of the time even just by chance it's
going to pick the numeric variable
that's the best about it okay so the
treat itself has that bias okay
now the tree there were being built in
party were designed to counteract that
bias okay and they have other ways in so
this is something I should mention for
those of you who use actually boost its
variable importance measures or based on
these tree splits so those are
vulnerable to this
by us okay in random forests you have to
variable importance measures one you get
for free okay the other one you have to
say importance equals true if you don't
say is true it doesn't do that
that's the permutation that I explained
okay you have to say importance equals
to perform will be with this permutation
base and that variable importance gets
rid of majority of that bias so it's a
much safer variable importance measure
to use okay so in XD boost I think it
has something called auto back there are
bold importance you have to use that to
you know avoid the bias otherwise all
the other things that you get for free
from the algorithm well I mean there's a
price to pay
right so this is something you can okay
so the question is what happened when
you have highly correlated variable how
those random poets deal with that right
some people say you might get the wrong
interpretation think about if you have a
dataset where you accidentally repeated
one of the variables in your dataset
how would you avoid them deal with that
will you do a question you get a
singular you can't do the inversion if
you use two are basically have no
solutions in these black box method it
doesn't care about these highly
correlated variables because all you're
doing is prediction you don't care about
interpretation if you don't care about
interpretation having highly correlated
variable is not a problem right it's
only a problem when you try to interpret
the data it try to interpret what a
model is telling you if you just have
two highly correlated variable and both
of them are important okay what happens
is the varible importance measure of
those two will be somewhat reduced but
if they're really important it will
still be higher than other variables but
again that's problem in the dataset that
you know you can't really blame mouth
algorithm right oh wait
you know it's interesting that what I
should say that if you have if you're in
this large piece mall and problem
meaning lots of variable and not many
simple size those kind of data and
especially if you expect only a few of
the variables to be important random
forests probably is not going to be the
best it's going to work ok it's not
necessarily going to be the best ok
because when you have very few data
points you're limited by the number of
splits you can try and if you're doing
this random split you and you pick the
variable that's not it doesn't give you
a good split you wasted the chance ok so
in those situations that will do well no
like I said will do ok it's not going to
be the best and where random forest will
do very well is if you have in addition
to something important variable you have
a bunch of variables that have very weak
effect random forests will give those
guys a chance to show their stuff
basically
right the way the way that's maintained
now is every time I got a version eyes a
bit up in virtually I'll put it up get
up okay
I can't really hear you
thank you
well I I hope I've given you some
comparison of deep knew on that and
random forests right so random forests
by the nature that girls treat them to
the maximum size the more data you have
the more compact that's going to get
whereas with deep nuan that you
basically pre specify how complex the
model is going to be it's the same way
with convolutional neural network ok all
the parameter settings in the
architecture the network attack sure
that you have either in deep neuron that
you know fully connected network or
convulsion
they basically determine the complexity
of your model ok so those who did
predetermine when you before you start
training you cannot change it after you
start training
I'm sorry I'm sorry I couldn't get that
I'm afraid I'm not familiar with that
sorry we have one here first order order
the hands go up in there
right right so so you when you have
correlative arable they have to share
the importance but if you if you don't
care about sorry well I mean if you have
the same variable just by accident that
happened in the data twice right so you
know Rena forest will happily use both
of them because it doesn't know any
better right so what happens is that
whenever it could use this variable
that's going to randomly pick one or the
other right so they basically share the
glory if it will and therefore when you
assess variable importance they
basically share the importance so both
of them will be slower than if you only
have one copy in there all right
the forest I think people who grow more
than 10,000 trees perfectly you don't
need that many trees for good
predictions so as you can
I couldn't really say why but just for
prediction performance it's quite rare
that you need to have more than 100
trees that's actually the case so the
the 30 data set that I showed you
regardless of how small or big the data
set is they're going to grow 100 trees
ok I guess one of the things is that
because the trees have grown through the
maximum size so by nature of doing that
you're already making the tree adapt to
the data complexity right well adding
more trees doesn't help you further
basically if you're doing variable
importance you need lots of permutations
so you want to do more trees but not for
prediction performance basically in most
cases I really see the necessity to do
more than 100 trees if all your all you
care is prediction well you're averaging
these data points there is a diminishing
return as to because you're repeating
exactly the same process right so how
many data points do you need to
approximate a distribution basically
that's the way I think about
well
right that's the bias week we just
talked about well I mean if that's
something that you really worry about
party is the thing for you because in
growing the tree I try to counteract
that bias I try to make it fair for all
variables basically yes party
partitioned I forgot what a white stands
for but that's the package you if we go
to crayon and say look up the party
package prty it has the c3 and c4 us
those trees will avoid that bias
yes
okay
well I can think of one example is if
you have some uncertainty about each
data points right so data points where
you're more certain you want to give it
more weight data point with less
uncertainty you want to give it less
weight right in Wrentham for us we don't
have the option of specifying weights
for data points I mean one possible
implementation is when you're doing the
random sampling you can use the weights
there so a data point with more weight
it's more likely to get sample that's
the easy way I can think of their
importance between two forests growing
on the same data set if you compare two
different segments of the same data set
I would say yes different signing of the
same data I will be surprised if they
give you drastically different results
well I would say don't take the
magnitude too seriously so the way Jerry
Friedman used or Express has the
variable importance in his version of
boosting he simply scale the importance
measure from zero to a hundred so no
matter what data said you get you always
get minimum a 0 and maximum a hundred so
it's he calls it relative importance so
you can only interpret it within the
dataset basically all right that's not
like regression coefficients
[Applause]